what role has violence or do you think
violence has played in the evolution of
homo sapiens so we are
quite an intelligent got a beautiful
particular little branch on the
evolutionary tree
what part of that
was played by
our tendency to be violent
well i think that violence was
responsible for creating your homo
sapiens
and
that raises the question of what homo
sapiens is
yes
yeah exactly
so you know nowadays people um
begin
the
the concept of what homo sapiens is by
uh thinking about features that are very
obviously different from all of the
other species of homo
and
our large brain are a
very rounded
cranium a relatively small face
these are characteristics which are
developed in a relatively modern way by
about 170
000 years ago say you know that's one of
the earliest skulls in africa that
really captures that
but
it has been argued that
that is a um
an episode in a process
that has been
uh started substantially earlier and
there's no doubt that that's true you
know homo sapiens is a species that has
been changing pretty continuously
throughout
the
length of time it's there
and it goes back to 300 000 years ago
315 literally is the the time
the the best estimate of a date for
a series of bones from morocco
that have been dated
three or four years ago at that time and
have been characterized as
earliest homo sapiens
now at that point
they are only beginning the trend of
sapionization and that trend consists
basically of grassonization
of making
our ancestors less robust
shorter faces smaller teeth a smaller
brow ridge a narrower face
a thinner
cranium all these things that are
associated with
reduced violence
okay so that's that's saying what
that's homo sapiens beginning so it
began sometimes three three to four
hundred thousand years ago because by
three hundred fifteen thousand years ago
you've already got something
recognizable so you're more on that side
of things that there was this gradual
process it's not 150 170 000 years ago
it's
it started like 400 000 years ago and
it's just it started three to four
hundred thousand years ago and and if
you look at 170 it's got even more like
us and they if you look at at a hundred
it's got more like us again and if you
look at 50 it's more like us again it's
all the way it's just getting more and
more like the moderns
so the question is what happened between
three and four hundred thousand years
ago to produce homo sapiens
and i i think we have a pretty good
answer now
and the answer comes from violence
and the story begins by focusing on this
question
why is it that in
the
human species
we are unique among all primates in not
having
an alpha male in any group
uh in the sense that
what we don't have is an alpha male who
personally beats up
every other male
and the answer
that
has been
portrayed most most richly by
christopher boehm and whose work i've
elaborated on
is that
only in humans
do you have a system by which
any male who tries to bully
and become the alpha equivalent to an
alpha gorilla or an alpha chimpanzee or
an alpha bonobo or an alpha baboon or
anything like that
any male who tries to do that in humans
gets taken down by a coalition of beta
males
um that coalition yes
it's a really good uh picture of human
society yes i like it okay
so and that's the way all our societies
work now yes um because
individuals try and be alpha and then
they get taken out yeah i mean we don't
usually think of ourselves as beta males
but yes i i suppose i suppose that's
what democracy is
exactly yes exactly
um okay so
well so at some point alpha males get
taken out
well what alpha males are are males who
respond with high reactive violence
to any challenge to their status you see
it all the time in in primates some
peter male thinks he's getting strong
and and uh
you know maturing in wisdom and so on
and uh he refuses to
uh kowtow to the alpha male and the
alpha male comes straight in and and
charges at him or maybe he'll just wait
for a few minutes or and then take an
opportunity to attack him
the
um
all of these primates have got a high
tendency for reactive aggression
and that make enables this possibility
alpha males we don't we have this great
reduction as i talked about earlier
and the question is when did that
reduction happen
well
cut to
the famous experiments by the russian
biologist dimitri believe
who tried
domesticating wild animals
when you domesticate wild animals what
you're doing is
reducing reactive aggression
you are selecting those individuals to
breed
who are most willing to be approached by
a human or by another member of their
own species and are least likely to
erupt in a reactive uh aggression
and you only have to do that for a few
generations to discover that there are
changes in the skull
and those changes
consist of
shorter face
smaller teeth
reduced maleness
the males become increasingly
female-like
and reduced brain size
well the changes that are characteristic
of domesticated animals in general
compared to wild animals are all found
in homo sapiens compared to our early
ancestors
so it's a very strong signal that when
we first see homo sapiens what we're
seeing is evidence of a reduction in
reactive aggression
and that suggests that what's happening
with homo sapiens is that
that is the point at which there is
selection against the alpha males
and therefore
the way in which this election happened
would have been the way it happens today
the beta males take him out
so i think that homo sapiens is a
species characterized by
the suppression of reactive aggression
as a kind of incidental consequence of
the suppression of the alpha male
and and the story of our species is the
story of how the beta males took charge
and have been responsible for
the generation of a new kind of human
and incidentally
for
imposing
on the society
a new set of values
because when those beta males discovered
that they could take out the previous
alpha male
and continue to do so because in every
generation there'll always be some male
who says
maybe i'll become the alpha male and
they so they just keep chopping them
down
in discovering that they also obviously
discovered that they could kill anybody
in the group
females
young males
anybody who
didn't follow their values
and so this story is one of um one in
which the males of our species and these
would be the breeding males
have been able to impose their values
on everybody else and there is two kind
of values there's one kind of value is
things that are good for the group like
thou shalt not murder
and the other kind of value is things
that are good for
the males
such as hey guess what when good food
comes in males get it first yes
so i mean it's fascinating that that
kind of set of ideals could out-compete
the the others
do you have a sense of why
or maybe you can comment on neanderthals
and all the other early humans why did
homo sapiens
come to succeed and flourish and all the
other ones all the other branches
of evolution died out
or get murdered nowadays when when homo
sapiens
meets homo sapiens
and we don't know each other uh
initially
then conflict breaks out and uh the
uh more militarily able
group
wins
you know we've seen that
everywhere throughout the age of
exploration and
throughout history
so i'm i'm rather surprised you know the
conventional wisdom i that you see
nowadays in contemporary anthropology
is very reluctant to point to
success in warfare
as the reason why sapiens wiped out
neanderthals within about 3000 years of
the sapiens coming into europe 43 000
years ago
and
people are much more inclined to say
well the neanderthals were at low
population density so they just couldn't
survive the demographic
sort of
sweep
or the disease came in and you know
maybe those things
might have been important but
you know far and away the most obvious
possibility is that
uh sapiens were just
um
were powerful
they had
everyone agrees they had larger groups
they had better weapons
uh they they had projectile weapons bows
and arrows to judge from the
little microlith
bits of flake
which the neanderthals didn't
you know nowadays there's
evidence of of interbreeding
quite extensive interbreeding between
sapiens and neanderthals
as well as with some other groups
and sometimes people say well you know
so they loved each other they made love
not war
i think they made love and war
and
it wouldn't necessarily mean too loving
i mean
if you just follow through from
typical ethnographies nowadays of when
um dominant groups meet subordinate
groups they didn't know each other
then you can imagine that
neanderthal females would essentially be
captured
and taken into
sapiens groups
you